simple characters in game of thrones
histories is not dead Deseret alive and
well and is one of the faceless men Oh
Bravo's that the theory I'm going to
introduce you with in this video when
you look at it Rhaegar Targaryen and
Jackie Hegar have a lot of similarities
fans mostly point to the fact that both
of them shared the same grace and had
the same long wavy hair
if Jackie does indeed turn out to be
Rhaegar the Silver Streak in his hair
would not be the only indication of it
as there are many more clues in both the
books and the show series i know that at
first glance this might sound impossible
or even ridiculous but i highly
suggested to here at all clues and some
kinds of proof that are going favor to
this theory let's start from the very
beginning from Reger's alleged death the
story says Prince Rhaegar met Robert
Baratheon in combat at a for during the
battle the Trident where the pair had a
legendary duel in the raging rivers of
the trident Rhaegar despite wounding
Robert was struck down with a massive
blow from Roberts war hammer which
scattered the Ruby's sing crusted in
rakers Armour under the water it said
that rubbish flew like drops of blood
from the chest of a dying Prince and he
sank to his knees in the water and with
his last breath murmured the woman's
name
Willa Rhaegar lays that in stream
soldiers so both army scrabbled in water
to search for the rubies the raft heard
the location was named a ruby fort
according to a semi canon source Reger's
body was cremated as its traditional for
fallen Targaryen let's firstly point out
the obvious it's highlighted that rengar
wore his iconic Knight black plate armor
with the three-headed dragon of House
Targaryen decorated in rubies on his
breastplate
additionally the Ford in which this
battle took place his name for the
rubies that were not from Prince Reger's
breastplate now why is it so important
for george RR martin as well as for the
showrunners to make it very clear that
rigueur work is a coin Carman that hit
rubies attached to it
why so much focus on records rubies why
is it such a big plot point and subject
brought up whenever the battle the
Trident or egg are brought up the first
theory would be that Robert did not
fight Rhaegar but rather someone else
who could glamour himself in the form of
Rhaegar using rubies as it's been
confirmed in six seasons and rubies can
be used to glamour its owners into a
former person they wanna be messenger
used as a to hide her true form of an
extremely old woman in the books mance
rayder glamour to appear as Rattleshirt
via the rule being his risk of the power
in rubies is something called glamour or
you can basically use them with the
power of the Lord of Light to project a
different image of yourself
if Melisandre and
man's can use it it's most certainly not
out of the realm of possibilities that
someone had glamoured himself in the
form of rengar using these same rubies
and sacrificed his life for the beloved
Prince the other theory that is also
supported with quite a bit of clues says
that someone else died instead of rengar
wearing his iconic armor remembered that
in the books because he was covered from
head to toe in armor then he was not
able to see his face in the vision in
both theories what I'm proposing is that
Rhaegar never died on the Trident and
that he's the faceless man that we know
is shocking hogar in both theories
regard well in the first theory it was
someone who used rubies to glamour
himself in the form of rengar in the
second one it was simply one of the
King's Guard members who fought Robert
dressed up in Reger's full armor
throughout the books we've been given
more than a few major examples from the
northern fighter vs heroes armor to
sacrifice his life for him and his cause
in a Clash of Kings Rodriquez al
attempted to put an end to Ramsay and
his atrocities Rodricks party comes
across Ramsay during one of his hunting
trips where Ames is able to survive by
switching clothes with his personal
servant who is then killed in his place
basically Ramsay gave him his clothes
and markings of identity whereupon
Rodricks men killed that servant
believing him to be Ramsay another
example can be found no less between
Robert Roy still s the bronze King
centaur de Saron the founder house Turan
it says it was dusk when artists and his
Endel army finally appeared but even in
that fading light Robert Rose did not
fail to mark their leader his silvered
Armour and winged how made a Falcon
night and mistakable even from afar
after the first six charges against
Roberts line failed our diseased Falcon
shaped helmet appeared in the heat of
battle
Robert charged at him in hope that the
Endel army would dissolve if their
leader was killed there we had two
legendary heroes meeting and fighting in
a duel except for a fact one of them was
just an ordinary night robber beheaded
the Falcon night after duel only to see
five hundred fresh and all Knights
charging at him with artists terrain at
their head esteeming cunning even more
than brute force parties had clad one of
his knights in his own distinctive armor
to distract row bar after Ward's artists
became king of the mountain and well and
found it how serene those are only a few
examples of someone else wearing their
hero's iconic armor to sacrifice his
life for him and his cause there's
obviously a reason why george RR martin
is giving us these examples there's also
one detail from the popular episode
Blackwater that supports this theory
when the episode came out George Armand
was
pretty upset that main characters likes
tennis and the hound were not wearing
their helmets during the battle HB
explained that it would be hard for
people to make out which character is
with their helmets on at first glance it
might seem strange that Jorge would
complain about those little details but
it actually makes perfect sense for him
to later reveal the tragg are never
fought Robert on the Trident a big deal
would obviously be made about one member
of the Kingsguard wearing riggers armor
and helm after the follow House
Targaryen and the world believing him
dead in the Styria Reger went to Braavos
and how so black and white to become a
faceless man just as Arya Stark did when
her house had fallen and when everyone
thought she was that if rigueur in fact
is not joking it would also be very
strange that some random faceless man
would allow himself to be captured and
thrown in the black cells without a good
reason
however if it truly is record then he
had a very good reason to get captured
which is returning a favor to Ned Stark
or protecting his child as we all know
when your request prisoners to take the
black the black cells are emptied out
and jaqen H'ghar is among the prisoners
jackeen accompanies this group all the
way to Harrenhal where he begins to form
a special bond Victoria now you might be
wondering why would Rhaegar help Arya
she's a daughter of a man who helped
Robert Baratheon's rip his family's
claim to the Iron Throne
well Rhaegar never held that against Ned
since it's his father who killed Ned's
father and brother and even requested
nets and Roberts heads so Ned did not
really have a choice also as I already
said Rhaegar kind of fog net to protect
arias instead protected his son John
it's definitely not out of the realm of
possibilities that Rhaegar came back to
King's Landing as jocking to try and
help protect the child of a man who is
the sole reason his son John is alive
and well it's also quite interesting how
it seems like Jackie insolia an area
from the very start in one of their
conversations Jackie says to Arya a girl
has more courage than sense this
sentence was also company in with a
smile on his face everyone who knew
lianna claims that Arya is just like her
not only by look but also by courage and
wildness this is what Ned said to Arya
Arya you have a violence in your child
the world blood my father used to call
it Liana had a touch of it and my
brother Brandon more than a touch it
brought them both to an early grave
Liana might have carried a sword if my
lord father allowed it you remind me of
her sometimes you even look like her Ned
continued sir egg are not only helps
Arya but he also later trains her to
become someone she just like currently
and I always wanted to be a person
capable of defending herself and
family it's also important to highlight
that if jogging is some random faceless
man assassin he would not be happy and
proud of firemen she would claim her
start name and rejected to be no one
neither would he allow her to leave the
actor who plays jogging Hegar recently
sat down in an interview and he had a
couple of interesting things to say
he only added the fuel to fire me he
said if you change the order of the
letters of jocking Hegar it leaves
Rhaegar and people began to try to
justify that Jackie was Rhaegar with
photos' long hair his grace he teased
there certainly is a possibility that
jock in effect is Ryoga and that he will
appear once again in the final season to
reveal the truth for his son John but
also to play a major role in defeating
the night king however while I do
believe that Jackie will appear one last
time at some point of the final season I
don't think his true identity will ever
be revealed in my opinion we will never
find out whether Jackie in Israel
Targaryen or just some random faceless
man assassin who happened to resemble
Rhaegar and be kind to Arya regarding
Jackie's reappearance it will happen in
the first episodes of the final season
Jackie will sneak into Winterfell
disguised as northerner and will reunite
vitória Jackie will then say tuara dead
the many-faced God requires another
death or a shocked and surprised almost
like to say that she's not no one but
rather Arya Stark of Winterfell pointing
out that she is not assassin and does
not plan to obey any order not to kill
anyone for the many-faced God
Jackie would then reveal the name of a
person whose death is required the queen
of the Seven Kingdoms Cersei Lannister
the Starks enemy the one who betrayed
the living side and is conquering the
Seven Kingdoms for the Great War rages
or a stark already wanted to head the
capital and execute Cersei Lannister in
the very beginning of the season seven
which means that she would most likely
accept this offer in order to cross so
possible the biggest name in her kill
list basically the one who would hire
the faceless men to put an end to search
his reign in this theory would be the
iron bank upon realizing that they've
invested in wrong ruler as Cersei might
cause the follow Westeros since she's
not supporting the living side Yaron
bank will hire the faceless men to put
an end to Circe's madness
let me know your thoughts about this
prediction of mine but also let me know
your thoughts about Rhaegar being alive
and well instead of that could it be
possible a jacking isn't some random
member of a feared mysterious assassins
but his rider prince who he believed was
defeated in battle the Trident could it
be that someone used rubies to glamour
himself in the form of Rhaegar or could
it on the other hand also be that one of
the King's Guard members fought Robert
dressed up in Rhaegar's armor and
profess his life for the beloved Prince
many fans have always believed Jackie
was Rhaegar the Silver Streak in his
hair perhaps he became no.1 when vest
Rose was being torn apart by war and his
outer faces to hide his true identity
until the time is right